ragazzi siamo al penultimo episodio via
way out maledizione se non ci fossi
apparati culo ciccio a con l'auto
proprio guarda a ciccio che ho preso la
patente dell'altro giorno guarda come
sono bravo
vediamo ciao io so ballare tu tu tu tu
tu tu michael jackson ma jesi bravissimo
dei deficienti spaccati dei deficienti
eravate la metro a un metro di chi ha
gli arruolati questi ragazzi li ha a mio
zio col parkinson che chiaramente ma
così no dai raga perché vedono che è
morto sparare meglio dei capelli che
minchia bionda è un problema o scherzo
you must mi ci devo andare in messico
mia moglie incinta già portati via
max co
stiamo partendo sul serio con tuo padre
ma che bello che permette sembra dire
appunto siamo arrivati qua quando ci
scegliamo il personaggio ben oltre
quando l'abbiamo mai visto no infatti
no no no baby
e a
cos'è messico eccolo qua ma a loro con
gli diano come fanno a sapere dove si
stanno lanciando loro lui ha detto lei
messico dove ok allora allora ciccio te
lo spiego io come sta spiegando io sto
spiegando marito spiego io come in four
nights ma quale ok pensare nella saison
vai mantieni certo non io vado e vai vai
a puccini chi la sta vivendo bene arrivo
è dov'è bene madonna che bello allora è
la sua bellissima come si fa tu vai e
vai a prendere subito il mood ma non
tirarlo adesso spetta un buco era un po
ok volevo dire subito questo potrebbe
essere il dubbio che questo potrebbe
essere un problema
questo potrebbe essere provati piglio io
dipingo io
[Applauso]
detta anche perché alcuni non essere
brutto beh hai fatto l'unica cosa che
non dovevi fare sbilanciarti il
paracadute è pro crearono in aria se ti
rendi conto che ti sei riuscita a far
altro che stiamo esattamente andando
sulla roccia o quasi beccato il punto ea
capo club stati bravissimi gente si
potrà togliere sei riuscito a togliere
di paracaduti una cosa andò ai party
questi qua veramente procedura rbe
allora hanno evasi di prigione anno sono
scappate all'ospedale pisano di polizia
e un parà caduto senza che nessun poco
mirá mirá anche se infatti sono in 3 1 2
tu devi smitragliate parquet a quei due
io devo sparare in quel movimento
quando uno due tre
ucciso uno perfetto anno gli importi di
forza beh quello è lì dietro i cespugli
ok
bravissimo stata fatta siamo bravi come
faceva tutto va bene io vorrei capire
dove stiamo andando
di qua sopra di una mano vai vai come
potevamo scavalcare benissimo ma vabbè
ma perché o no questo lo facciamo fuori
casa in italia
kat forse il cecchino cosa da fare
no io non ho c'è chi non è me 14 ma veda
i tuoi su ok e io provo a vedere il 69
82 su sicuramente uno deve farla
rischiarato da girarlo con mille perciò
io intanto il rotolo sulla scala non
riesco a salire dice ok è bello è lieto
di fare no là in fondo ragazzo se tipo
della stop a questa parte fa cup che
rotola rota l'altra spesso entro quale
ha suonato a lui la cosa schivato mai o
che ci sono perfetto amici sarebbe stato
d'acqua io mi sa che non può esatto non
possiamo uscirci spara subito nello stai
aggirandosi praticamente dietro occhio
no se scassata la scala in ordine scala
di legno
nell'imboscata cecchino io però vedere
se riesco a di strangola anche bravo
bravissimo
ok adesso tocca ai l'hai fatto già porca
vacca occhio prendici chi no
occhio perché ormai siamo andati a
comprare armi perché sennò è un casino
bravo ciccio troppo della stoffa giusta
parte del gip ha infatti va benissimo
occhi occhio ops bravo che l'altro
da bravo ci piace questo modo come morto
questo è un po così la faccia centro
dentro la porta mi scoccio di 1200
contro miliardi grazie non buona non ci
sarà un motivo
ecco ci casco
io mi fermerei il secondo ad ammirare la
bellezza del paesaggio ma che bello che
bello è tesa a messina mi sa di no
chissà che questa non è messina nota che
costava da mastore bent e kakà
dappertutto si è così pensare che quello
sta spuntando sta spuntando butta giù
tutta la puntata questo sto vedendo nel
mondo della vita può andare perché
chiaro io sempre
dobbiamo scolare la pasta vino si chiama
del caricom e facciamo salire a questo
scopo che si spingono carrello in acqua
questi spingono cosa li spinge va bene
ma mi sa che gli abbiamo rovinato la
macchina passato aspetta
ok ma [ __ ] siamo dentro questa la
casa di harvey quale stiamo
tranquillamente come due persone civili
dai permesso
sembra sembra il finale di gta san
andreas è quella dove devi sparare con
tutti quanti per lui piacciono ed è lì
l'inizio che non possiamo colpirli
stufato di caprera ecco è non so cosa
devo fare
dovrò fare qualcosa non ho capito ma
devo aprire la porta ma che ho trovato
lancio questo appare aspetta e si impara
la mia 3 1 2 e 3
pare che cosa farà sbarra bravo ma così
si fa così ciccio è morto lo dice sì
direi di sì questa roba di le visite per
formati che sorpresa come le armi an
tubi don blasco hatten chi insomma ci
caccia di atene
riconosco la piscina e la villa di armi
e mi chiese che proprio non ci si può
far tesoro o
maledizione occhio comune luca umberto
lo ha fatto prima
ok va bene ma scusa l'uno vai perfetto
bravo bravo bravo così occhio dove
harvey non lo so credo altri ok ok per
ora è morto mai posto un miliardo di
colpi con bin saqr ma vai pure io ci ho
pensato su vedrai si può fare ma sistema
prima dell'anno poi tuffarsi in piscina
10 sostiene in piscina ora non saputo
resistere la guerra tra privato un
puntino la infront a sfavore mette armi
o ocse in italy si perché ha un
lanciagranate di quelli maria coccia
per aver tranquillamente demolendo il
caso superstock
con la
non è un fenomeno il fenomeno
qualora infatti fuori voglio andare su
tricarico ricordi su ma dov'è il tipo
eccolo perfetto ce l'abbiamo fatta
aspettano non c'è fabio berto e
fortissimo lui a me 6.000 brutta però
c'è alberto lo ha colpito non è morto
però ancora morto ma d'oro e harvey hai
una casa bella però gioni 20h tanti che
in 2 abbiamo fatto sto casino quindi
comincia il prossimo evento o una pista
una pistola d'oro che il tamarro ce n'è
andata davvero
berna ciò che dispiace vuoi farlo è per
forza non sa mai
prego e tutto tu hai fatto il bullo per
tutto il tutto il gioco vai tu allora
patti chiari amicizia lunga come il mio
naso come mio caso non saper dire
abbiamo ormai siamo sulla stessa
lunghezza d'onda ci siamo ci siamo
precisi si dica troppo calmo costi trema
la mano jones
le quinte che google ancora cto come
loro immessi andato subito casa sul 9 ma
non importa bene così poi dirla proprio
cercas per occhio che nella cassaforte
c'è qualcosa sicuro se come non ci sono
sceso in diamante ci fa saltare in aria
qualche modo occhio da invece no
temporary store la faccia a vista da
vero quando neanche lista pensate io
cosa sto facendo lì la statua ma credo
spostati spostati poco ci spiano spingi
spingi spingi sordi beh allora ucciso
era veramente difficile marcarlo
ancora vivo ma basta vice pali se va beh
se va a colpi in testa vabbè mi sa che è
morto però non ne sono sicuro io andrei
a controllare non si sa mai
vai tu scendi du cirque tuffo su fatti
un fatina qua sacrificata anche io avrei
subito arriva la polizia mi ha le mostre
le moto le moto mix seguita però
dobbiamo invitare tutti ad uno deve
guidare una e una davy dall'altra salve
grazie è stato bello farlo per uno sparo
anzi di secolo con le macchine lei non è
bene non c'è però adesso dobbiamo
dobbiamo guidare tutti e due non solo
una persona già quando guidava uno era
un casino non si capirà niente ma va
bene tutto guida fai finta di niente
quinta ciccio vedere che la patente
celebro motivo che sono rossoblù io sono
qui da ma edizione non preveda il freno
contatti non roma ancora una volta 3
fresco perché marcia indietro o ai vari
thomas chioma sgomma sinistra
ora cav h opera una cosa e schivato tu
faccia come l'ho fatta sincronizzare
questa roba quando hanno programmato il
gioco a letto vabbè ci sono certo al 100
così non mi spiego manson dei maghi
occhio si vabbè gta abbia fatto stato
insieme e va beh come com'è possibile
la pasta in furious league la vecchia se
l'impresa di mercato hanno questa dice
non è esatto ai mezzi gol
no
io adesso penso di spararci addosso di
tutto e la passione per la musica
esatto a chi che si sta sparando sarò
[Musica]
sono morto io no come si nota ancora
sono incastrato fatta omerta arrivati
vari vario rio cori così me frega io bye
bye ciccio ma io spero si va beh wow
cioè per crei può accompagnare sono
sinceramente vesco quel punto il punto
questa gente fra il ruggiero salis ali
come facciamo a salire sull'aereo in
questo momento spiega mi io ci sono dati
alla mano se e va beh
james bond che salta salta ti rendi
conto di cosa abbiamo fatto
non siamo neanche mai morti così
tranquilli dei fenomeni no io schiera
lettera subito a mia moglie
se fossi in te se karamoja ho evitato il
diavolo sono il diavolo toni il diavolo
tra i predict sei bravissimo dovrei
visto parecchi presto nuove stesso se
assunto eccolo qua la lettera su una
cartolina dal messico ma la moglie leo
ed infine un bel personaggio e cariboni
nasti barriere grigio a milano
sì sì a cominciare dalle sciarpe a non
muore mai
esiste il classico dei giochi bene
sembra fasi nella prigione abbiamo fatto
un miliardo di cose ospedali che abbiamo
battuto un tipo che viveva in una villa
manco pablo escobar chiara si butta
sotto la cappa no no non avendone vero
no non è vero non è vero non ci credo ma
lo conosceva sopra che erano qua con
dimmi che la ragazza non dirmi che non
ci posso credere
già venduti la zia già venduti la tipa
dell'aereo beni già venduti lei non ci
credo maledizione
parlava reed amici guarda tranquilla
pezzo
kikkio
picchia ben si vuol dire cosa ho io ve
lo giuro regalo di sicuro
voi non avete idea del finale non avete
idea uscirà tra un paio di giorni non ce
l'avete l'idea ve lo giuro non ci avete
un'idea io non dormo da quando
registrato quella cosa li dovete vedere
il finale che avevo giocato siamo
arrivati fin qua è veramente incredibile
incredibile
io spero vi sia piaciuto al costo vivo
giornate mi piace con i centristi sono
solo così si chiede e noi ci diamo da
ragazzi
[Musica]